special announcement coming in hot added
to rough and rowdy 19 December 9th I put
together one hell of a crew with talbas
fight companion show we will be watching
it live with the boys we're talking Theo
Von Joey Diaz Rampage Jackson myself
[Music]
oh goodness oh wow
what else you want tune in
right through the city like British
[Music]
if you ain't thick please don't get
involved
now Brandon
foreign
what's up fam see what I did there I was
waiting I was keeping you guys on that
your seat yep I was keeping you on the
edge of your seat usually I talk right
away not today not today because it is
past Thanksgiving and I am just full of
that dry ass turkey I'm so full of that
dry turkey baby dry turkey for the win I
actually hate turkey I wish they would
change the the tradition of eating
turkey on Thanksgiving maybe switch up
to Pizza maybe
um a nice Pizza be nice my mom used to
do that back in the day I always thought
it was weird but I appreciated it she
was an outlier
um maybe even a nice steak would be nice
mix it up this dry bird this dry turkey
man not a fan it was nice though you
guys did the traditional Thanksgiving
chin yeah
family
I would be I would love it but we're not
family's not doing it my family there
was no duck served no duck we just it
was pretty much all American style
Thanksgiving but then a side of kimchi
and some you know Korean side dishes I
appreciate that yeah case traditional
straight up dude straight up brought the
girl over to the fan for the first time
big Thanksgiving moment for you was it
awkward at all anybody make any awkward
comments
but your brother was like you know Casey
used to use boogers you know some [ __ ]
like you know what brothers do nothing
wow big moment for you mark Thanksgiving
with wifey
what's German
oonchizer bratwurst
a
we had schnitzel Brothers
turkey meatballs that's nice
balls on balls and some cranberry a lot
of balls going on for Thanksgiving over
at the Mark household that sounds nice
though yeah we had that traditional
um
white Thanksgiving man we gotta switch
it up but did we did have a little bit
of Mexican flavor on there because they
have uh tamales
every tamale tastes exactly the same hot
take my Mexican family's gonna hate this
every tamale tastes exactly the same my
girl like oh it's the best of my you've
ever had i'm like [ __ ] they all taste
exactly the same dry corn there's
nothing to it this is the weakest [ __ ]
I've ever had then bossy had his b day
tamales you stood your ground I see I
didn't though dude I didn't man I didn't
they there was definitely
um there's definitely some tamales up in
there if you can pecan pie here's the
thing about pecan hot take again uh love
pecan but with my current state of my
teeth I can't eat pecan pie it is the
absolute worst thing for my teeth
the kids are balls deep in football
right now my their Grandma my mom sent
only one football helmet between two
kids so one kid has a helmet the other
doesn't it is a disaster there was I
mean they're getting CT young man
tires put it on Wedge Buster I'm like
dude he is three why are you breaking
the wedge right now
yep and then also I had to regulate on
the Mexicans because
um they wanted to put World Cup on
during Thanksgiving
I think it's the only time the World Cup
was during Thanksgiving it is ridiculous
you're gonna put you gonna put Germany
Saudi Arabia the hell they're playing
over
over Washington Redskins I'm sorry
watching Commanders
you're gonna put them over the Denver
Broncos lady the Dallas Cowboys versus
the Giants are at your goddamn mind it's
America lady America
and I wanted to bet with them I said if
uh if the U.S beats England we have to
call uh football soccer
no one took the BET and then the family
is super disappointed on my son's
birthday which is on Saturday because
Mexico played Argentina and they come
over in their Mexico jerseys and they
weren't paying attention to my son I'm
like this [ __ ] these people man and I
said Kate real quick you realize Messi
lost the first game against Saudi Arabia
like literally won the biggest upsets of
all time Saudi Arabia beating Argentina
I said you realize it's messy he's top
three to ever do it debatable number one
to ever do I you think he's gonna let
Mexico be you know they did not like
that so they're all eating their tamales
and of course my boy Messi every five
foot six of them kicks that stupid round
soccer ball through the back of the net
beat the brakes off of them they were
not happy dude not happy messy doing the
goddamn thing mess got a little bit of
trouble because took a Mexican football
jersey and cleaned the locker room uh
floors with it and then Canelo saw that
who's Mr Mexico was like Hey messy you
better watch your back when I see you
it's on
I think he said you can get these hands
muchacho
he didn't say muchacho but I feel like
he should have
but also uh Canelo if there's one guy
with more money than you it's uh Messi
and his security is thick
kennel Alvarez threatens Messi's
isn't it funny how Mexico left soccer
but they're not very good
strange like it's their [ __ ] like they
gather on the TV for that [ __ ] and
they're just not very good it's just not
like in the U.S we're like okay
hopefully I do all right like we tied
England and people are celebrating like
it was [ __ ]
you know like your team won the Super
Bowl
because we tied England zero to zero
I love people like my girl's family talk
[ __ ] about American football I'm like
hey hey first of all
I watched two hours and nobody scored a
single point and you want to complain
about American football you got your
goddamn mind see there's messy and he's
taking the Mexican Jersey now maybe he
didn't know it see uh oh he just kicked
it off yeah that's it
oh there it goes I think he's stepping
oh no I can't tell to celebrate also
Argentina
take it easy you beat Mexico
and we probably lost to Saudi Arabia now
um I saw a thing actually Jonathan Shaw
my older brother sent to me where every
player in the Saudi Arabia team was
gifted a Royals Royce a Rolls-Royce
there you go Rolls Royce Rolls-Royce and
uh apparently that was a lie and uh be
like the comments you gotta check your
facts and a lie oh I'm sorry I didn't do
an essay on Saudi Arabia soccer before I
posted that I don't give a [ __ ]
also Instagram flag this misinformation
if you want I I saw it I'm like oh
that's lit I don't give a [ __ ] they got
Carson I thought that was cool they sure
as hell didn't it the coach came out I
was like we did not give them rolls
royces
they're lucky they even get a [ __ ]
ham sandwich Saudi Arabia baby you know
and then I heard they made a national
holiday and then someone who lived out
there was like it's not national holiday
how dare you
all right man this is the news we're
getting over here I thought it was a
cool story my bad
some positive for Saudi Arabia for God's
sakes what do you want me to do
but overall man uh good to have a little
time off time with the kiddos get that a
hell of a b day
his b-day still going on because his
school celebrates it today which is it's
like why won't you do it last week man
why would you do it after the fact you
know kids are gonna kid Man kids are
gonna kid around that's what they do uh
entering fight weekend before we get
into it though next Friday it is the
companions of all companions because
your boy signed a deal with bar stool
Sports and we are covering rough and
rowdy December 9th it's Providence Rhode
Island New England which I just learned
last week it is New England and I put
one hell of a squad together for the
debut companion for rough and rowdy bar
stool thick boy cow bass fight campaign
you got Theo Von the Rat King himself
one of my brothers from an older mother
you have Joey Diaz Coco Joey Uncle Diaz
is flying to LA to do a fight comparing
[ __ ] he's coming out here and he
also got Rampage Jackson
the man the myth the legend UFC royalty
coming on down Pride royalty coming on
down then my dumbass will be there as
well and they got the bar stool Squad
you got Dave Portnoy you got big cat you
got my boy Robbie you have the whole
Squad there as well that is going down
next Friday December 9th live on thick
boy you watch on thick boy YouTube
that's at 8pm Eastern that's 5 p.m
Pacific we're gonna have one hell of a
time they uh decided to use I guess
we're all in suits there
we're dressed like that for somebody's
funeral that's exactly that that picture
was Tate this is how old school that
picture is that picture was taken at the
spike man Awards
that will never happen again there's no
man Awards going on anymore spike is no
longer here there's a man Awards and
there's like
reading like steak with our hands the
servers were like Hooter Girls it was
insane it was insane Brian didn't know
who Kendrick Lamar was he was sitting on
our table like you know who that is
right and Brian's like who's in that
little guy with this I'm like he's like
the best rapper alive he's like no I'm
like okay
you're 70. okay
but theobon joy Diaz Rampage hell of a
crew man it's gonna be a fun time I
can't wait and we have a companion the
falling Saturday to the next Saturday
the day after this one and you can watch
it live and that will for everybody else
you can watch it on thick boy YouTube uh
by Tuesday or Wednesday I think we're
gonna do that and we have Brian Callan
the great Sam Tripoli and a very special
guest so that's coming up man but
we gotta blow this thing out fam support
your boys support bar stool support uh
the thick boy Squad that's uh next
Friday at 5 p.m Pacific time so I'm
excited for that man good way to close
out the year I'm speaking of closing out
the air only one tour date left man for
the 2022 oh he thick tour the OE thick
door definitely carries on next year of
course but
I don't know I gotta plug clear my ears
like I'm flying a Spirit flight whatever
it's Monday baby
um the last date for uh this year is
December 1st through the 3rd that is
this Thursday Friday Saturday Providence
Rhode Island a place I've never been for
great things about this club from all
the East Coast Comics it's the comedy
connection Providence Rhode Island and
that is Thursday Friday Saturday those
shows are almost sold out so if you list
this right now go get your tickets we
have exclusive thick Boy tour merch can
only get in person might have a few
jerseys there that already sold out as
well so make sure you come by and uh say
what's up big J shop will be selling the
merch we also have tiger thick whiskey
there as well so Providence Rhode Island
you're up baby then we're putting
together right now I have more news on
it but 2023 is coming in hot it's gonna
be for the folks in Canada we're gonna
do a big ass Canada run and I'll have
news hopefully we seal the deal today so
I can announce it but I'm super excited
for that the dates were 2023 on there
now you have Naples Oklahoma City Tacoma
spoken but we have dates in January and
Feb we coming up to so looking forward
to it man
Province Rhode Island you're up baby
all right let's take a little break from
me chatting here off about the fight
game Providence Rhode Island this
Thursday Friday Saturday last date on
the oh he thick tour that's Providence
Rhode Island this freaking Thursday
Friday Saturday at the comedy connection
tickets are almost sold out we're not
adding shows I can't make the flight
back if I do that because I'll be up all
night so it's five shows one Thursday
Two Friday two Saturday Providence Rhode
Island you're up baby tickets that
thickboy.com or
fatkz.com this episode of the shop show
is brought to you by my friends at
manscape it's never too early to play
holiday music all right I disagree with
that but this is what they're telling me
it's never too early to start a thing
about gifts whether it's for a friend or
friends in your pants you can make this
season to be jolly with manscaped do
your little drummer boy a favor use the
lawnmower 4.0 to avoid another silent
night in the bedroom nobody likes bushes
especially around
Christmas time just makes sense a smooth
Bush says you're a fan of Santa Claus
then add in the manscape's top of the
line shower products to have a people
saying All I Want For Christmas Is You
Baby Santa cares about his sack so
should you look nice when you get
naughty and get free shipping and 20 off
by going to manscape.com shop listen
I've been just pushing manscape non-stop
this entire 2022 this entire year I've
been talking about manscape and then I
was in the hotel room on the road the
other day I thought I was in Houston and
I didn't have my Platinum package 4.0 I
didn't have that ultimate package that
Platinum package all right I didn't have
the two in one shampoo all right I'd
have the lawnmower 4.0 body trimmer and
the weed whacker nose and air here
trimmer all right I didn't have any of
that stuff so I just use your regular
old trimmer and dude my nuts were a
nightmare it looked like Freddy Krueger
did his work it looked like I burnt my
nut sack like I deep fried him like a
turkey for Thanksgiving it was a
complete mess I forgot how good the
Platinum 4.0 package is I forgot that
the lawnmower 4.0 body trimmer and it
has the light on it all right it is a
freaking Wonder that this thing isn't
put in the Guinness Book of World
Records for the best thing for your nuts
because I'm telling you it was a mess
down there so if you want to play it
safe you want the best freaking product
on planet Earth you gotta get that
lawnmower 4.0 get the Platinum package
you get all the goodies you get all of
it and they give you a little bag all
right get the ball toner the crop
reviver you get the the shower gear all
right we get you get all that stuff and
you can save 20 off and get free
shipping by going to manscape.com shop
schab that's 20 off with free shipping
at manscape.com shop manscape get your
jingle balls ready for the holidays
listen fam this one's easy I'm holding
it here you always see it on the chair
it's always in my mouth when I'm doing
stand-up podcasting interviews TV
working out riding my bike with the kids
at the playground flying on a plane
you're always gonna see me with a fat
lip because I got Rogue nicotine in
there if you're a regular viewer you
already know how much I love Rogue I
reached out to them to be part of my
business I love Rogue nicotine I use
their pouches every single day Apple's
my favorite I'll switch up from time to
time with the lemon drop and the mango
I've been pushing them to a grape I
would love a grape all right I love it
and they have all different sorts of
flavors Wintergreen peppermint mango
Citrus they got it all Rogue also makes
other great products like gum tablets
lozengers however you want to get your
nicotine I prefer to do it this way but
have you want to do it nothing beats
Rogue I love that I can take it anywhere
I want flights comedy clubs no
restrictions nobody knows and I get
through TSA fine with it I my bags
completely Rogue products because I
freak out if I don't have at least 15
cans while I'm on the road because I go
through it like crazy I use the six
milligrams I pop for these pouches baby
that's how I do but Rogue is my go-to
source for nicotine when I'm riding and
Performing I love it if you want to try
the pouches like me or the gums tablets
everyone get your nicotine go to
roguenicketing.com use the code rogue20
for twimps off your order again that's
Rogue 20 for 20 off your order under age
sale is prohibited warning this product
contains nicotine nicotine is an
addictive chemical for more information
visit rodenickteen.com all right let's
get to it man uh the biggest news over
the weekend listen you have a big
weekend coming up with fights you have
Tyson Fury fighting which is my favorite
combat sport Athlete on the planet and
then you also have a great Fight Night
in Wonderboy
and um one boy and Kevin Holland going
at it and that's a great fight which we
will get into
um so we got a lot going on this weekend
you have a one championship fight which
to me is the best fight of the weekend
and I've seen a lot because you have
Tyson Fury fighting then you also have
Wonder Boy who's a UFC Superstar and
Kevin Holland who's a UFC Superstar but
it's the last one this year uh it's one
Championship on Prime video it's the
number five you have RDR versus malikin
for the light heavyweight title if you
don't know who these gentlemen are so
Malkin is the interim Heavyweight
Championship champion from Russia right
and he took the belt because the the
champion was in a contract dispute so he
did an intern belt he's they're both
undefeated
they're monsters Malkin is a Russian
Savage wrestling his thing but he has so
much power in his hands he is a Savage
again he won the belt by knocking
homeboy out his right hook and left hook
are Savage he's only six foot tall
Russian though that's all you need to
know
the gentleman that he is fighting I
don't care what organization you want to
compete in he is gonna be a top five guy
in any weight class so not only is he
light heavyweight champion he's also the
middleweight champion he's a Jutsu
Phenom he's out they call him the Dutch
Knight he's Dutch right his uh he's from
the Netherlands his
um record is ridiculous again he is not
only a middleweight champion of the
world in one Championship he's also the
light heavyweight champion of the world
now he's fighting the heavyweight
champion of the world this dude is a
Savage RDR is what the kids known by he
is good in every aspect of mixed martial
arts you could put him in any
organization in the world and fight for
the title and he's given everybody proms
not only at middleweight but also light
heavyweight I'm telling you this kid is
a big freaking deal man he is a Savage
he looks for the finish this guy went to
a draw with Andre gaval in just jiu
jitsu
Savage super Savage so I'm looking
forward to this man and that's this
weekend it's it won championships last
one on Amazon Prime and that is Saturday
at 9 00 a.m and so that would be so it
says December 2nd Friday 8pm Eastern
December 3rd Saturday 9 A.M uh Singapore
time Mall of Asia Arena Manila
interesting I'm looking forward to that
fight though I can't wait for that fight
it's the best fight of the weekend and
I'm telling you if you're not familiar
with these guys Americans listen to this
this RDR character I'm telling you get
familiar and that Malkin for a Russian
this dude has personality for day son
four days you'll see the little
highlight video that doesn't wet your
whistle I'm telling you you gotta get
into it you gotta get into it man
um but the biggest news over the weekend
was Kayla Harrison lost
what's interesting about this is Kayla
Harrison I actually think this is good
for the pfl because you're so dominant
and I'd be curious at the pay-per-view
numbers this is the first pay-per-view
she was fighting a girl on Larissa
Pacheco that she's beat twice and you're
trying to sell that as a pay-per-view
it's a tough freaking sell because
Kayla's Harrison's so dominant this is
actually good for the pfl it's actually
good for Kayla Harrison brings more
interest into the sport so she's just
dominating these girls no one really
wants to pay for that which because
would you pay for Kate Harrison versus
Larissa Pacheco before it known this
result like no should have beat it twice
I thought and she's gonna you know it's
not like she's this exciting knockout
art she just dominates these girls takes
them down beats them up some go to
decision some don't so for this I think
it's good for the pfl overall I think
kale Harrison needs to be your dominant
Champion but her taking loss similar to
Izzy I think is actually good for
numbers good for uh pay-per-view buys I
think in the long run this actually
helps pfl actually think that helps Izzy
helps the UFC in the long run now but
with Kayla Harrison
or her uh agent or manager
um
ali uh said this and I quote he put um
so Ben Astron this is I don't know how
long ago but uh kale Harrison is a
Savage and Ollie put uh again who's her
manager I love Ali but if she ever lose
I will leave MMA she cannot be touched
MMA is a crazy sport MMA is a crazy
sport so to say that
um you obviously have a ton of
confidence in your fighter but it's MMA
there's too many ways to lose that's why
it's the hardest sport to bet on it's
hard sport to pick on that's why nobody
you know if you're batting 50 you're
doing a damn good job you know
but this one I don't think anybody saw
coming I think that Pacheco is like a
plus [ __ ] 1100 10 to 1 odds or
something yeah it's nuts he was a big
big dog so
um and honestly they're just at 4847 I
don't even have it at 49 46 I think I
probably get 49 46 48 47 all right at
least you guys got it right you didn't
screw over Pacheco but I think Pacheco
has set the
a blueprint if you can do this where
she's in such phenomenal shape
you're gonna get taken down when you
fight Kayla Harrison you need to take me
out sure as hell you need to take down
the thing is you gotta fight down there
you gotta fight down there so she
doesn't want to just
take you down and control you down there
and that's what Pacheco did and I don't
she didn't just give her the takedown
Ace made her work when she was going for
a takedown she was blaster in the face
so she's getting hit at all freaking
times so to me this has a little bit of
Mike tyson-ish there if you remember
Mike Tyson completely dominating guys
dominate dominate Dominique then when
they meet somebody they can't bully and
they stick up to them they kind of you
know they show up a little bit and when
they realize they're in a fight and it's
not just going their way and not just
smoking people they can't be a bully
that's even in regular life if you're
dealing with a bully once you stick up
to the bully he's gonna move on to a
weaker person
so for Kayla Harrison again she's not a
bully her fighting style meaning she
dominates in every aspect but Pacheco
came in such phenomenal shape and that's
the key takeaway here anybody fighting
Kayla Harrison next I'm sure they can do
a rematch but whoever fights are next
you got to realize you're gonna get
taken down
but if you learned anything from her one
loss is that you gotta make her work man
you're gonna get taken down but you
gotta have the the wits about you gotta
have the talent even off your back
you're throwing the kitchen sink at her
whether it's knees oh I'm sorry if it's
elbows punches submission attempts uh
Pacheco had a great triangle attempt she
almost caught her in with Taylor
Harrison can't just do what she does and
dominate and control you on top and she
has to work that's a lot of energy man a
lot of energy the key here is Pacheco is
in such damn shape that she didn't give
Kayla Harrison an inch in any FAFSA this
fight she made her uncomfortable even
when she has a dominant position Pacheco
still made it work even when she had
Mount she created a Scrambler get back
to the feet then when she got back to
her feet she made it count so we know
that Kayla Harrison's so damn good at
takedowns right that's her thing and
being the aggressor she's like okay
can't stand with her so you know she's
gonna get you down and Pacheco did such
a great job making her freaking earn
every single takedown and when she did
she was getting hit in the face even
when she got taken down she can hit in
the face creating scrambles getting on
top getting back to her feet she just
did the perfect fight and for Taylor
Harrison it was a rough night man she
got beat up dude you look at her face
she got beat up even though she died
made the fight control wise she got beat
up every single round it was a dog fight
that's the only way he can beat Kayla
Harrison and if I'm fighting her next my
take away from that if you're not
Pacheco my takeaways you have to be in
phenomenal shape to fight like that for
25 minutes have to be
I think this action get more
pay-per-view buys on the next pfl
pay-per-view because I'm like damn this
girl Peter let's see if Kayla can figure
it out when you're just dominating
people just assume you're gonna win stop
on Tyson remember people want their
money back may not come boy out like 19
seconds
my dad ordered it was like what the [ __ ]
I want my money back dude this is
ridiculous
so I actually think this is good for
Cale Harrison the other there's two
great stories so for Pacheco who losing
twice ended up beating the most dominant
female fighter in the sport right
um UFC won championships the most
dominant female fight in the sport Kayla
Harrison was Untouchable till now uh but
the other great story is that Brendan
Brendan uh Lohan low hey Ren Lohan you
remember him if you're a fan of the uh
Dana White Contender series
he had great fight he had a great fight
right and they just didn't award him a
contract he goes okay cool most people
like God damn it maybe stop for me and
move on and get a different career he
stuck with it and then he just won again
on the same pay-per-view pfl card he
just won pfl's featherweight title and
got a million bucks million bucks great
story man
get his nose broke but great story
a million bucks that's amazing million
bucks man great story
so yeah overall though
um I'm curious to see what the
pay-per-view numbers were like on that
I'm really curious man also that uh
Olivier Auburn Mercier who's he had a
great knockout yeah
you got a million bucks Aspen Ladd did
the damn thing he wanted to yeah
Marla Mariah's man
tough one yeah
another tough one for him I don't know
what he's gonna do you know but overall
good fight card
good fight card and then you got uh you
know the UFC fight night this weekend
obviously the The Talk of the Town the
talk around the water cooler is Thompson
it's Thompson right versus Kevin Holland
and Kevin Holland ah i i people think he
was just trolling us when he said he's
gonna retire I think after what happened
with the homsap fight he's like all
right I made money I'm good man and he
has a ton of fights he has more fights
than Wonderboy and Wonder Boys damn
they're 40 years old one boy's 39 I
think so one boy is number six in the
world Kevin Hall and the UFC rewarded
after doing a solid fight in homdot on a
30-minute notice
um you know he got tough in a in a rough
position they're dry too he gets that
that anaconda darsh choke I forget what
it was maybe darce he gets him in that
while he's dry nightmare complete
nightmare obviously you know he wasn't
set up for Success during that fight
but I think you know people think oh
Kevin Hall was trolling us he was just
forcing the uf's hand to give him a
fight remember he said I'm sick of
wrestling I'm sick of dealing with stuff
I want somebody who's gonna stand with
me so he does what Kevin Han does and he
goes I'm gonna retire
and even Dan was like man I like this
kid I don't think she retire Hamza was
just a tough matchup for him he does a
solid so he goes unless it was something
unless it's a perfect fight I'm just
gonna stay retired you'll see he goes no
no we don't want to lose you thanks for
doing a solid
and also how the UFC contracts work they
just don't get an idea and then an hour
later submit the contract so
once he announced the retirement I'm
sure there was talks of Wonder Boy
so there has to be some Labs there so
maybe he's trolling maybe he's not maybe
he's seeing if the UFC's serious if
they're actually giving the spike Heroes
I'm sick of wrestling I don't want to do
that so all right here's a guy who's
absolutely not going to wrestle here's
Wonder Boy Thompson you want a striking
match here you go
if this was a younger one boy Thompson
um and I think Trail went on to say it's
the worst matchup possible for Kevin
Holland I completely disagree Channel
you know I absolutely love you and
respect you he says a complete uh
nightmare of matchup for Kevin Holland I
disagree I think with uh wonderboy's age
and his fighting style
um age and his fighting style don't go
hand in hand they're polar opposite so
to have his fighting style he's
different than like an eight Diaz or
like a DC or Randy Couture these guys
who fought when they're older where they
can adapt in their fighting style they
don't need the really explosive in the
spring in their step Wonder Boy has to
have that spring and spring in a step to
fight the way he does on his toes and
you know keeping people at the end of
his feet and his base his feet are
basically his hands you know so with his
style he has to have youth on his on his
side and it's only a matter of time
before Father Time catches up with him
one could argue that it has caught up
with him because he's lost 1 two three
four five he's lost five on his last
eight nice face in the who's who here
he's fighting Woodley Mazda doll Darren
till Anthony Pettis Vicente Luce uh Jeff
Neal Gilbert Burns and Leo Muhammad we
just saw how [ __ ] good Muhammad is
right so you know it's not like he's
fighting just
mediocre guys he's fighting the tip of
the spare guys here and he's losing my
decision he's Vic he's only been
finished uh really I mean he got
finished by uh well now his only finish
if memory serves me right was Anthony
Pettis Anthony Pat's the only one to
finish him
outside that he's a hard guy to finish
you know a lot of he loses by decisions
but I do think father times catch up
with Wonder Boy which we should start
calling Wonder Man now and absolutely
love Wonder Boy but at 40 it's hard to
call him a boy right he'll be 40 in
February I think so
um
yeah I I I disagree with jail here I
actually think it's a great fight for
Kevin Holland because what Wonderboy
needs what uh What uh one boy Thompson
needs is he has a very traditional style
where if you go technique for technique
with him you're in a world of trouble
because he that's all he knows that's
how he came up he has the fundamentals
down like nobody ever before in the UFC
he's very hard to train for like Julio
Machida that style is hard to mimic
but his style is very traditional
you're not getting a lot of things where
if you brought in a training partner
especially at his age now if you brought
in a Taekwondo specialist a karate
specialist a kickboxing specialist his
movements his explosiveness isn't the
same anymore he does get hit
and the way you beat a guy with
technique right if guys get thrown
straight down the pipe the thing that
beats him is the guy that's thrown
unconventional and that's Kevin Holland
so one has their black belt and crazy
Kevin Holland one has their black belt
in traditional striking which is Wonder
Boy but at 39 soon to be 40 that
traditional striking once it slows down
and the footwork slows down can be in a
lot of trouble with a guy who's eight
nine years younger than Kevin Hall and
has his black belt and crazy and in Jiu
Jitsu but he also has a chin because one
boy fans himself a counter Striker and
Kevin Holland does bring the pressure I
just think for five minutes we're gonna
see
since Anthony Pettis fight Kevin Holland
get a finish I wouldn't be surprised for
the first time too in a while Kevin
Holland also has a severe advantage on
the ground when it comes to grappling
and the transitions in the Jujitsu he
has a black belt so he would have a
significant Advantage down there now how
he gets him down obviously his
wrestling's not great one boy is [ __ ]
tough to get down even at his age it's
tough to get down but I wouldn't be
surprised if Kevin Holland gets it done
via submission as the fight goes on when
a boy slows down
the only other caveat here is you know
one boy is a veteran when it comes to
the five round dance Kevin Hans not that
familiar with five rounds at all in any
facet Wonder Boy has been doing five
rounds for a hot second hot second so
the advantage one boy there experience
as far ago as as it goes is striking
goes Wonder Boy but overall MMA
experience goes to Holland and he has
youth on his side and he has the I don't
give a [ __ ] on his side and I'll take
Kevin Hall in this fight I think he gets
it done I think he finishes Wonder Boy
which is impossible to do oh if you're
in a bet that would be the bet I put the
props on that are pretty damn good but
I do think Kevin Hall gets it done and I
bet you this is Wonder Boys last fight
I bet you can't finish and he retires
whoa yep that's what I predict's gonna
happen
who knows rust card's good too
rest card's a it's a it's a good for
fight night it's pretty lit Nico price
if you look at Nico price on the UFC uh
poster on the on their website it is
Andrew Schultz
bring that option you guys know me when
I do these face comparisons it is Andrew
Schultz the infamous Andrew Schultz keep
going keep going oh he's on the prelims
for this there he is look at him
schultzy if schultzy had a bench press
and hit some incline that is Andrew
Schultz
the man who's the face of comedy podcast
right now shout out to my boy Andrew
Schultz he is Nico price there's a
picture I'm gonna look for real quick
new price is always fun too yeah I'm mad
at him at all he's super fun though I'm
telling you whole card be tough to pick
five tonight on this one
that's why this dude performance to the
knights now because this can be tough
people think Schultz looks like uh
aspinal yeah and there's a certain
picture that came out and looked really
similar
maybe a little bit noise
it's hard to you got to see the picture
look at his hair's right maybe I guess
he does that's why it looks like if me
and Schultz had a baby aspin all looks
like if me and Frank mayor had a baby
Frank Mir is a good comparison to you he
looks like a a young Frank mayor
that Schultz announced in his dates
ah same picture I guess it's Flag they
took it down to have music or something
no it was just a picture I don't know
what happened but did it have Tom Aspen
on it yeah it was Tom aspinel and
Schultz actually replied to it saying is
this you know people are saying that I
look like him or something like that
it's Schultz if he got on trt
and like it's just a face I I think
Schultz looks more like Nico price than
that UFC thing than anything he looks
pretty similar pretty similar they both
look like the uh
the Wario character not war is that
Wario's the fat one the bad oh it's uh
Waluigi
Waluigi that's what Schultz looks like
and aspinal and Schultz that's not I'm
not this is all love for Schultz
that's a tough one to spell huh how am I
trying to figure out I see you dog oh
there you go yes yes that's sure Andrew
Schultz was right there there's Sheltie
right there
and that's a skinny aspinal
yeah definitely Schultz
and I'm Wario
I've had a mustache on Mario
but neither one of us is mean
yeah that's me I'm Wario I'm a figure
Mario
is so mean in those games
I know nothing about these games which
is you don't know Mario Bros I mean the
old school Mario Brothers I mean Mario's
pretty old school man came out in 19. I
remember Mario or oh wow interesting
Super Mario Mario
sucks for you
sucks for you sucks for you oh it's
always Black Friday at on it they always
giving out deals it's Cyber Monday too
we're talking 25 off the best
supplements on the planet 25 off Alpha
Brain usually hear me talking about 10
off if you use the promo code uh Shob
nope it's 25 off they're doing 60 off
door busters they're getting rid of
stuff 50 off digital workouts where you
can download workout programs to get
your thick ass in shape 10 off Fitness
we're talking about kettlebells steel
Club maces battle ropes you attempted
off that 20 off nutrition protein
powders Warrior bars they get off 27 20
off apparel and gear so if you want to
look fly while you're working out you
get 20 off that again 25 off supplements
60 off door buster deals 50 Off
streaming digital Fitness temperatures
off Fitness Gear like steel Club Macy's
kettlebell somebody just died out there
20 off nutrition protein powders all
that stuff twin soft gear on it.com shop
you save additional discount there but
right now the entire website is on sale
and all right it's on sale right now
their Hydro Core bag is on sale for the
next 24 hours you get 15 off that bag so
hurry now they're doing a flash sale
again 25 supplements the best
supplements on Planters 25 off the
number one sell nootropic on the planet
talking about Alpha Brain on it.com job
you're welcome now let's get back to the
program what else you got so Anthony
Smith had a take on
Conor McGregor because holler's been
going off yeah that dude has some free
time and I figured oh it's the holidays
there's no Thanksgiving in Ireland he's
just having to some [ __ ] he's just
firing back at people he even went after
Brogan I was like whoa Bubba what are we
doing here yeah so I mean here's what
Anthony says
uh and then I'll show you Cottage
response so there's only one reason you
would do that someone said on believe
you me podcast which is him and Bisping
great podcast by the way uh he's looking
jacked as [ __ ] he keeps seeing videos
and flex in front of mirrors and
screaming he's huge he healed really
fast like really fast
uh so basically Smith is implying that
Connor was doing obviously you know PDS
to get back to whatever and avoiding
usada yeah Luke Thomas really got into
it with usada on Twitter he was lighting
him up like I'm a smart guy yeah now
it's like and he was just
yeah so Connor's uh responds to
um
Anthony Smith here's this The Audacity
Of This loser they put at Lionheart
Smith you're a loser
two losers there
he said lose it twice all right uh The
Audacity Of This loser at Lionheart
Smith you're a loser the percentage of
the bones joining back after a break
like this is so low you think I'd give a
[ __ ] about anything else I'm the most
testifier of all time combat sport
I give everything to this game you
nothing
uh I thought you broke your leg yourself
in your last fight hello you little dope
your embarrassment oh man keep my name
out your [ __ ] mouth prick and then he
just keeps going ah walk it off you
little tick broken leg my bollocks
embarrassing so that's Anthony Smith
being carried by two guys
um helping him walk yeah my aunt Smith
he broke his ankle
it's got my food truck the next day he
had to have surgery
I mean some sort of fracture right yeah
yeah and he's literally we paid for his
five that's why we don't book Fighters
anymore unless her name is Bo Nichols a
day after a fight remember bro [ __ ] so
Anthony Smith we set that rule we're
like all right we're not booking anybody
the day after fight because who knows if
I just get hurt we don't want Bank of
though it screws up our scheduling and
then they called and like hey Bo Nichols
want to come on food trying to book them
like well he wants to fight in Vegas
then he'll come over after he has a
fight I'm like book him
really buckham he's the only guy book
him him or Jon Jones book him
uh everything was fully disclosed before
I began the state of allowance for at
least recover from issues as horrific as
the one I overcame must be assessed my
thoughts are with widen Ashton Silva the
three of us and only us know the
severity of this injury
and then he left a voice note too
another creepy one let's take a listen
how do people do these I know I just
discovered these like you didn't first
time yeah apparently he just puts it on
Twitter yeah I'm about doing for my
to Anthony
Smith here yeah
you know reports came out your last bill
you broke the leg right you're sitting
there you're sitting there hobbled over
the oak what was the extent of the
injury it was silence area for an area
trap on that
so obviously it was a miscalculation
didn't break your leg but what was it
was it a stress fracture what what was
the issue about no he broke his leg
because his ankle right you know what
that looks like for me you hobbling out
there it was what I experienced pre the
break what I went through in the camp
and in training and have them stress
fractures and they were building up over
time even over [ __ ] years of building
people around yeah they built up over
so cute
until then strap your leg up and keep
[ __ ] going get back in that cage and
kick until the leg [ __ ] fully snaps
and then you'll be at my level yeah and
then go about what you got to go about
you I'm a big bad machine what can I say
God decided me
and God decided it
yeah uh
so this guy put if he had crush your
metatarsal Buns on the foot as well then
you're talking horrific because you'd
lose your spring you had a
straightforward break of the fibula and
tibia effect it will be stronger than
before with no loss of Mobility
uh he goes I crush the metatarsal bones
in my foot three weeks before the khabib
fight and still made the walk that's
gangster oranges are not the same you'll
see it on the Netflix doc yes coming out
when a serious injury with a high
percentage of never recover occurs it's
just simply not the same the Mack Daddy
of fighting puts him with a dope Daytona
gold Rolex
yeah I mean
you know somebody was going to take that
smoke that Smoking Gun because when you
want to just talk [ __ ] about Connor he's
not one to just take it and lay back so
you know he's gone after everybody so
for Anthony Smith it's actually a good
thing yeah you know there's a lot of
Connor haters out there and they're
probably on the Anthony Smith train I
don't think it's
crazy for Anthony Smith and some of the
MMA
experts or media to say that Conor
Beyond a yacht and getting not being
tested while he's recovering from an
injury one could assume that he's taking
PDS especially when he's jacked
but on the other end of that it could be
Connor is a freak when it comes you know
to physicality he's a freaked it he's
looking at his shoulders when he's built
what he's done in his athletic career
he's a freak so a lot of people you know
and some of these guys criticizes him
aren't freaks so they want to assume
that he's on things
now the chance of him being on things
are probably pretty good
and I'm not mad at any facet because A's
not fighting B he's the UFC's Cash Cow
he's their green elephant I would do the
exact same thing you know from ufcsa
take whatever the hell you gotta do to
get back and healthy because you're only
getting older the longer you stay out
it's not good do what you want to do go
on you got get your Gucci pajamas take
all the HGH whatever it takes to require
you to get back to full health do what
you got to do I don't have a problem
with it and he's not competing I think
athletes in general if you have an
injury of this magnitude should be
allowed they shouldn't be in the testing
protocol because they are going to be
taking stuff
now doesn't mean it's PDS but it's for
Recovery you know
I don't have a problem with it any facet
to get back to 100 in health because
when he does eventually come back to the
UFC
I guarantee they
Grant him uh an exemption which they
said they're not going to do and that's
when Luke Thompson got into it with him
but usada said that yeah they're like
the odds of us granted there you go
there are except exemptions but the
chance of doing exemption are not good
guarantee they don't shut your mouth but
also
um
you know when the he does decide to
fight he will be clean
yeah do you think they would let other
Fighters do the same kind of thing or no
no no right so this is just a very
unique case this is Conor McGregor yeah
it goes back to Jerry Jones thing uh
yeah Jerry Jones the the head coach of
the Dallas Cowboys on won all those
Super Bowls
they said um he'll just treat certain
players different it's just the nature
of the game and so they said uh you know
whatever the six round draft pick
quarterback fell asleep at the meetings
they go what'd you do he was I fired him
cut him and they go uh did anybody else
fall asleep because yeah Troy Aikman our
Star Quarterback what happens when he
fell signal to me and goes I woke him up
that's uh that's just Sports
where do you cut the guy not a chance
your job's Bank on the UFC you need a
cash cow
do what you gotta do get back because
when he does compete he's gonna be clean
okay
yeah it's a interesting loophole it's a
loophole and it's also like uh if you
took ibuprofen for swelling that would
be considered a PD you know what I'm
saying like there's different it's a
it's a dicey it's a gray area
if I'm Dana White like yeah dude do
whatever you do get better because
remember when he competes he's gonna be
100 healthy so I'm not and there's no
offseason in the UFC which sucks for
them but you don't think the NFL NBA
guys they're coming off these ankle
sprains or whatever it is are taking
[ __ ] to become healthy like their bodies
their business so they're going to do
whatever it takes to get back to full
health by any means necessary and you
guys judging Conor or anybody else
anybody else that's done things after a
horrific injury like that you don't know
what the [ __ ] you're talking about the
stakes are so goddamn High yeah I would
do the exact same thing so someone just
taking time off to do PDS to get bigger
or stronger not even bigger just to get
the the full health so people that were
let's say someone didn't get a horrific
injury they just did it they're like I'm
gonna retire for now and whatever and
come back later that's BS right because
that's [ __ ] this horrific injury
which you know he says like a wide man
or answering civil injury and which
wideband he said is also dealing with it
still correct today correct
so it's like all right well I do nothing
just let it heal naturally which is then
we're gonna be the same the legs can be
weaker why I can take some of this stuff
and comes back stronger and then when I
fight I'm clean
and you'll see I'm like yeah do you
Bobby do you buddy I don't have a
problem with that trip again the problem
is if you grant him the exemption which
you definitely you don't give other
people the other Fighters just want to
start doing it
but not everybody's counter
special rules for special Fighters it's
just
dim the rules
in every sport dim the rules yeah
alrighty um this is figure out racism
does she have a front I think she has
silver like a
like a rapper I always trip out on these
pictures too
like him just I don't know who this girl
is but just him hanging out with this
you know pretty hot girl
yeah his Jack City
yeah
super jacked
let's take the shirt off and chills
because they gave him uh someone gave
him a proper 12. necklace damn can you
know tiger Sigma down
dude that's a good idea yeah because the
freaking logo is awesome so yeah yeah
Cody garbrand got a tiger tattoo on his
face no way look it up hold on he I mean
yeah okay I know you're talking about
now is it the official tiger thick logo
I don't know that's up for debate maybe
my maybe my vision's not as good but
he's a down ass dude there it is yeah
boom tiger thick logo on half his face
that white is so cool that's nice yeah
God I would be interested see what this
looks like in a few years
hey man
people are lame
uh so this I thought was also
interesting
so this is give me sport boxing it says
uh it's just timelines of how many
minutes you're in in your fighting Sport
and how much money you make in those
minutes so it took Jake Paul one minute
28 seconds to earn one million took
Tyson Fury 55 seconds to earn one
million it took Canelo 43 seconds during
one million that to Connor earnings
permit are an absolute joke and I'll
show you his right here
holy [ __ ] I'm still I'm so bad at math
so I don't know
uh so it took Conor McGregor earnings on
the field 33 million minutes played five
minutes earnings per minute 6.6 million
dollars time to earn one million dollars
nine seconds so he's on top of this huge
list of you know Killers top 10 fastest
earning athletes of 2022. that's
interesting because
so on the field earnings so that means
the earnings that he made in 2022 so his
one fight against
so it says five minutes played so that's
where I'm getting lost
minutes play so five minutes of fighting
yeah just five minutes of fighting I
don't know I thought it was a five
minute uh five rounds or five whatever
yeah that's five minutes per round so
five yeah so five minutes the one round
because you didn't continue the second
right so the five minutes he made
33 million dollars
for that one round
that's one I'm already lost every nine
seconds
but yeah now Jake Paul responded which
is pretty funny he goes yeah but look
how old you guys are he's like I'm I
think 26. and that that's one fight
Connor coming off a long layoff
that dude makes so much Goddamn money
hold on What football players don't go
down
yeah football oh yeah football that Ryan
ramsick football 38 million
600 minutes 64 000 took him 15 minutes
to make a million loser am I right
and then you got Aaron Rodgers he just
got benched last night
yeah yeah oblique injury he's also been
had he's had a bad thumb All Season too
he's played with a broken thumb Matthew
Stafford he's injured too Josh Allen is
balling Kirk Cousins are Ballin Amari
Cooper doing all right
God damn those guys are making money but
damn not like Connor and that's connerly
fought once
that's crazy that's a cool stat
they're good for Jake Paul being up
there yeah for sure dude he just barely
got into this it's also good for a mixed
martial arts because the number one most
paid guys in the UFC
if you do the calculations yeah yeah
Bob's having this conversation with my
uh
my father-in-law because he's like yeah
you know everyone talks to me about UFC
fighter pay and he's like yeah but
boxing makes more I'm like they actually
don't overall if you take the averages
of from the prelims the main event UFC
makes way more money
the top guys you know in boxing yeah
they make the Lion Share the money
because the there's they're the only
name in town yeah but the UFC has a ton
of names on it overall they make more
money because that fighter who's a
co-main event or the third on the main
card they don't make [ __ ] compared to
the UFC yeah USC is always like you see
overall makes better money than boxing
I'm close but the outliers are what skew
the numbers yeah
Alex Pierre admits there was one UFC
fighter who scared him I thought he was
going to kill me
Sean Strickland yes
one of the scariest fighting the series
limit he was one who's skid he stepped
in the kitchen Sean Strickland wow and
everyone's scared of Alex but yeah right
but he was actually scared of Sean
Strickland he he interesting what
because I wonder why you scared him I
was scared but when I hear him talk I
relax a little bit he's a good fighter
and an experienced one but he was
talking some stuff that didn't make any
sense
yeah that's Sean Strickland that's what
makes him great for a few months since
the fight was booked out fair but I was
under control but I'll tell you when I
was the most afraid everything set up
until the way and everything was fine
when you entered the octane started
staring me hadn't looked at me that way
before that was when I became scared
he's another person inside the Octagon
different from his normal personality I
thought this guy wants to kill me I'm
telling you this was a different guy
from everything else but in the end it
was good that he had to knock in Octa on
this wave because it woke me up I became
aware of danger I know I couldn't make
mistakes I said damn he's different in
here you have to be careful with this
man I went in smarter managed to catch
him that's interesting it's so cool that
he admits this stuff yeah that's cool
especially at his you know dude has been
doing
[Music]
um
yeah Strickland's one of those guys
similar to there's not too many of them
similar to Josh Barnett where they
literally they're down to die in that
octagon like oh yeah he's such an
original
just one there's only one Sean
Strickland in this world it's correct
he's so crazy what makes Sean Strickland
an outlier you know in a top 10
middleweight in the world if you look at
skill set his toughness he's probably
tougher than most of them uh his
mentality it's just like we have to edit
it out because we don't want to get
taken out off YouTube but he was like I
have no Prime Time Well thank goodness
he found a sport where he can kind of
like Channel his that's what he said
energy he's like damn I can beat up
people and not get you know put in jail
I'm in he's damn good at it yeah he's
actually really skilled he's a big fight
coming up
Kennedy right
[Music]
this is a quick one I don't know if I'm
gonna play the video because I'm worried
about that so but this is basically uh
Francis agato's coach telling him before
the fight with the cereal gone yeah dude
he was like they don't care about you
they don't give a [ __ ] about you he's
right just pull out he's right but you
pull out yeah they don't care about you
pull out to your point they don't care
about you you can get left behind
and Francis he came on food truck
right after that fight killing food
truck cobbling in here shout out to
Francis and he was saying he's like yeah
I was gonna pull out the fight and I
called Kamara Usman come around like
dude you know any fights I went into
with the city on the train he's like he
goes I've won World title defended my
world title not even being able to train
three four weeks before the fight he's
like but mentally I'm so confident he's
like so you can do this man
so is coach Nick Sig said I know we all
know these [ __ ] don't give a
[ __ ] about you bro so why are we doing
them a favor
nagano's orthopedic surgeon also thought
fighting without an aclm sale was insane
so this the knee would be damaging worse
if we competed on it and he did it
anyone
overalls meniscus College looks good
right now
yeah that's insane that he went through
with it and
yeah yeah about a year already he don't
want to miss the fight and dude he is a
Savage yeah good for him paid off
big risk
now he's just sitting out trying to get
get the pay deserves
all right speaking of him
um so these are reports that are coming
in the UFC's wanting the angano fight
with Jon Jones for March but if he can't
do it at that time they're looking at
Curtis blades yeah I think we talked
about last week it came out an article
and I've heard this for a talk for a
while now the UFC's trying to fight Jon
Jones but they want him to fight Francis
so finally UFC went all right it's been
gone the games have gone on long enough
John's fighting at UFC 285 regardless
whether it's Sarah Sarah gone Curtis
blades hopefully Francis but regardless
he's fighting hope we can get the
Francis deal done if not he's fighting
curse blades or Sarah gone I I think
Sarah got the toughest matchup for him
oh Cyril yeah
yeah yeah with his style his athletic
ability uh the way he Maneuvers I think
could be a real problem for John I think
John beats everybody but I think as far
as stylistically uh Sarah gonna be his
toughest matchup
I thought curse would be like a super
tough matchup but I don't know Curtis
definitely not walk in the park Curtis a
Savage you know who beat most guys not
named Francis and Ghana like you know
he's a champion if he was born in a
different year but
um
you know I think
for Curtis he you know he's still
putting together his striking and
wrestling he has a phenomenal
world-class double leg
but that that's gonna be tough against
John just a regular blast double you
have to use some chain wrestling against
John now
that being said John does get hit in
fights and Curtis blades hits like a
Mack truck I do think
um John's Advantage will be in the
clinch there he'll be able to take
Curtis down off his back guaranteed John
takes coach down by the way guaranteed
and nobody takes Curtis down John will
take Curtis down inside leg trip from
the clinch this is a fight where John's
will be able to close the distance and
in in his clinch and his uh control in
the clinch obelo team down it won't be
an outside shot John take him down
Against the Cage like he took down DC or
do an inside foot trip against cage
something like that but John's uh
advance and come obviously outside I
think his IQ is really high and he puts
everything together the best we've ever
seen But John's gonna be able to close
the distance on these heavyweights which
they can't knock them out when they're
that close and he's the best to ever do
it inside fighting wow so I think it's
gonna be a tough fight for Curtis
but again John does get hurt and just
get hit and hurt and Chris bites hits
like a Mack truck so John's gonna have
to tighten things up at heavyweight
otherwise he you know when you Zig when
you should have Zach heavyweight ends
the fight at light heavier he's been
able to get away with it a little bit
heavy he can't you just can't
I can't wait
when you um you so you trained with Jon
Jones before right did you do a lot of
grappling with them or or mostly just
not a lot of Jiu Jitsu we did some arm
bar stuff that Greg had us working on
but I was just drilling
um and we spared a lot sparred Wrestled
a lot wrestled so you felt his power so
as a light heavyweight insane okay no no
heavyweight could compete with him
that's crazy and these are topless top
name guys yeah destroying all of them
not even close
all right well this is pretty good news
this is Francis zagano kicking a bag you
know it's not so it's not too crazy with
the leg that he broke yes
that's jacked up that's cool and uh I
just don't want to play the video yeah
and this is pretty crazy I had no idea
this is happening but I guess Dana White
had someone threatening his daughter I
didn't even know he had a daughter I
didn't know two boys yeah I had no idea
uh so this and that guy is I guess I
guess he's an MMA fighter he used to
work at the UFC either at the UFC or UFC
gym or something okay and then he he
made this like a weird handle like his
name and F the UFC kind of handle oh and
then he put it on his stories
oh it's about to get dark dataway is
probably looking for some creep on
Instagram he goes this is the guy that's
threatening mine at mine [ __ ] at
danaway and your kids which is freaking
crazy have your daughter in my bed soon
yes this is
I don't know what the hell that is that
makes it mind [ __ ] that makes sense
guys probably not mentally well no
and then I guess that's him Brandon
Voice or voice Bender Logan Murphy fuc
the UFC yeah
F the entire company and if you own a
piece you to all the owners so we did
that Dana White obviously caught wind of
it and then um apparently this guy's
caught now and this is I don't know if
we're gonna use this but this is Dana
White's daughter apparently
I don't even know he had a daughter yeah
uh so and then this is what people are
saying that guy is
so uh Millie Mafia says can someone
please tell me the uh can someone please
tell the rest of us what the hell
happened yeah that's Millie mafia shot
to Millie Mafia and uh
bras World Inc put someone threatened
his daughter and then William I said
some dude named Brandon Bender posted
some [ __ ] about F the UFC and Dana Hills
said he'd love Dana's daughter and his
best soon Diaz said if he wants
attention we'll give it to him and here
we are someone threatened they'll have
Uncle Dan's daughter in his bed soon Dan
Post the ACC and ask for the information
to happen the bloke seems they got him
already
um
and okay
I'm just curious
um
by the way these did he make a threat
I'll have your daughter and or your
daughters in my bed soon so that's kind
of
dude if someone said that about my
daughter oh I get it yeah no no I'll go
crazy whatever it takes but apparently
Dana White said we right here they're
gonna post a picture we got him and he
was asking for the public to find out
who the guy was and apparently Christ
but I didn't
he's the Bellator fighter oh [ __ ] okay
why is so much anger towards UFC was it
the employee from the U.S it said
employed but either the actual UFC or
like a UFC Gym something like that
so it's kind of like I don't know
um I'd be a hypocrite if I said I don't
watch it but admits he's not a fan of
Dana White's power slap League
I'm with Rogue I'll probably watch some
of it I'm not gonna be like glued to my
TV and like breaking it down on this
show but
um I'll watch some of it along with the
roads like I'm in like technique and you
know guys that put tons of time into
training stuff like that slapping is not
really that is it the one thing though I
mean they're so good at what they do
they know what and you see I'm like they
might see something we don't really see
right now yeah maybe it's entertaining
when we see the slap also it's you gotta
remember the attention span of society
now so short that's another reason yeah
super short so
um
so oh the sources for the Dana y thing
were MMA Mania and Madness MMA so I
don't know how legit all these things
are but this is what's coming out but if
Dana posted on us social media I follow
Dana I didn't see anything you saw a lot
of stories don't look at the stories oh
that's things yes as you post on his
stories screenshots the merge the post
and the interaction with the ledge uh
Predator X fighter UFC employee
Brandon benderology posted massaging
screen where you threatened you'll see
presentation and his family two and six
year old dude she's 16 too Jesus
doing it goes on
mother F and crackhead
yes
you can't do that by someone's daughter
new
yeah
apparently that's the guy
well
but Dana said he you know according to
the Articles Dennis said he got him so
oh everything's good to them just give
them a
that that because he's not saying he's
gonna kill or rape just in the bed but
she's 16 years old yeah
I don't know eliciting a minor Maybe
there has to be something for sure
listen to a minor and then there's a
threat there and he threatened Dana some
maybe I don't know yeah I don't know
either
but you can't say [ __ ] like that though
or I mean at least Dana White and his
friends or whatever can handle that you
know yes yeah they could go the dark
Arch route yeah dicey for that guy we've
never heard of but now we're talking
about but not in a good light no not in
a good life new
all right so this is uh Patty the Baddie
is 11 years ago he wrote this about
seeing Bruce Buffer
he goes 11 years ago this week I met
Bruce Buffer in Birmingham after the UFC
I told him in years to come you'll be
announcing my name in Vegas and in five
weeks he will at UFC 282 when I blow the
roof off the Gaff once again that's
great yeah and look how young he looks
there it's so insane he looks like the
most innocent kid on the planet but he's
about us yeah super badass
and then Bruce wearing the Silver Star
shirt I used to rock that I think most
people that were in MMA we bought that
they would send it to me I love my
favorite stuff that and uh I think
infliction reflection was interesting
yeah I've signed reflection like right
before they went under and then uh one
more round
I had the one more round
um oh what's his name the Texas cat
who fought Brock Lesnar in his first
fight
Pride cat
who fought Brock in his first fight yep
hold on let me see where I'm around real
quick
I guess they're still around too no way
the website's still up holy [ __ ] new
collection click on that I'm gonna have
to buy some of this [ __ ] oh you can't
even click on it let's go to the shop
now
no oh man they don't have anything but
they have face masks so they're around
at least 20 20. weird click on t-shirts
no no you can't even click on TV no it
says no products oh no products go back
to the pictures
I'll show you the one I had
it was so lit
let's go to images
I mean it looks pretty dope oh they were
sick dude like this is cool even though
it's oh I think it might be uh that one
chin the first one on the second row
first one in the second one yeah because
it's the cowboy for his name
it says they were sick
graphic tees were so hot back then
and they're so expensive especially back
then man Affliction was so expensive the
material is really nice yeah they were
nice soft shirts I think they sell it
the buckle
I think it's the buckle did you ever
wear TapouT shirts I was spots by tap
out yeah so you had to yeah yeah okay I
wore a tap out I wore Keith Jordan's Tap
Out shirt on my walk at uh to an
ultimate fighter when I walked out I
wore a Tapout shirt
nice I was a hitman guy though the names
I don't know if you could do it these
days Hitman clothing yeah they were they
got bought out by uh tap out so their
brand of tapping I used to wear the pink
Hitman shirt and then the pink uh black
and pink Hitman uh shorts too for fights
that's roots of fire here but that one
is yeah but these are okay I used to do
pink too yeah I wore those so those
white and black Hitman ones I wore when
I fought multiple guys
I never read more red because of uh I
played at CU since and we're not allowed
to wear red you know you can't wear red
on the camera no why because they hate
Nebraska it's like a rival so you
couldn't wear red what the one kid got a
red truck and they're like don't park
that around here
yeah facts and hopefully see you they're
looking to get Deion Sanders
they're looking to get Deion Sanders as
a coach and dude I don't ask her much we
got to make that a current event chin on
finding the kid I don't ask for much
from CU you need to give Deon Sanders
[ __ ] dial Ward if he wants it you
need to give him JonBenet Ramsey's house
all right that's a mansion I know it's
haunted but give it to Deion Sanders
they don't believe in ghosts whoa this
is 35 minutes ago what's it say Deontay
confirms head coaching job op confirms
wait confirms head coaching jobs
he's received a job offer offer oh
so it's between him and Tom Cable
but if he confirms he's receiving it if
he accepts it it's his then right yeah
oh they they offered him he so the
reason he's such a big deal is because
he recruits better than anybody so he's
at Jackson State he's like the top three
recruits in the nation his son's a
baller all that comes with him to see
you we suck we're one in ten we lost
last week by like
80 point they're so bad they're such far
cry when I played there dude if they get
Deion Sanders I will get a [ __ ] Dion
tattoo on my goddamn neck
I will sleep it would save the program
we can't compete if we don't get him not
between him and Tom Cable now did Tom
Cable call me two nights ago yeah he did
all right be cool see you Buffs baby
you know I don't follow football at all
but I saw interviews with Deion Sanders
and Michael Irvin their personalities
are so like fun and cool dude Michael
Irvin I've been around him a few times
is electric yeah now he's on there's a
reason he's on FL Network he's on first
take this morning
he doesn't like seeing a Smith get a
word in you can tell Stephen Smith
getting frustrated and that Molly who
runs it you know she's the host of it
she has to like play you know Steer the
ship Michael keep going she'll be like
Michael I'll take from here like he just
rants but he's so entertaining yeah he's
such a special dude yeah I told you that
story when I was at the Super Bowl party
with Tim Tebow and uh Michael I was
fighting at the time that you've seen
Michael Irvin
um we should definitely do an animation
on this Michael Irvin
um was the speaker for the UFC Summit so
we met there me and him knew each other
previously we played at golf uh charity
tournaments together so we we had a
relationship so he's like what's up
giving this big hug and whatever we're
talking and then months later it's the
Super Bowl and there's if I mean if JJ
Watts everybody's there right like the
who's who I'm like holy [ __ ] I'm in a
suit and then Michael Irvin season goes
be sharp in front of everyone like I
felt so cool like oh hell yeah and I go
to hug I'm like what's up baby and
everyone's looking at me and he takes my
head pulls it down he goes
kiss me on top of the head like I was a
kid I was like okay there we go okay
okay everyone's all that's fine what's
going on there I was like damn Irvin
just gonna kiss me on the head dude
what's up man went for a high five he's
like nah how's she reacting
oh hell yeah good to see you man and Tim
was like why is he kissing your head
like that I don't know I couldn't
control it though
dude he's the most like lovable
electrifying person I've ever been
around yeah
I remember that coach
dude I swear to God I see you get Deon
Sanders
it would make my Year man
well they're unwatchable right now you
can it's the worst football you've ever
seen played
once uh Hawkins got that program his
boys state and then just ramley made his
son the starting quarterback and was
like we're a school of good grades so
they stopped getting all the kids from
Texas and California and you know Ohio
and Florida all the recruits like oh
you're Stanford now [ __ ]
I knew we weren't going to win many
games we had two white cornerbacks I was
like oh we're screwed we're screwed
that's good can't do it unless that's
Jason C horn we're screwed
I dude I will
freak out if we get Deion Sanders well
looks like it's getting close
it's officially on offer yeah
everyone's like you think it's real I'm
like yeah why wouldn't it but then I
blasted out on Twitter I'm trying to do
my part to get D on prime time in there
dude I blast out on Twitter and
someone's like dude he's from South
Florida he lives whatever three miles
from the University you think he's gonna
take a job in Colorado like yeah dude
one of them's a big ass program with a
lot of history CU is a big ass program
with lots of money
South Florida what happened you know
decent conference ncu's going I think
they're going to the Big Ten Big Boy
conference you don't think Dion wants to
be part of that and C is just a stopping
point for him he's gonna try and get on
somewhere else you know but for a few
years to bring the program back dude
uh
one can help
maybe it'll happen
uh so I need you to pray too yeah maybe
play for prime time for Dion so this uh
we were talking about Patty earlier
Patty pimblet yeah he uh this this went
viral recently so this is Patty pemblin
he was taking his dog out for a walk and
the dog took a dump around This Woman's
porch and I guess it was so wet and
nasty he couldn't pick it up with the
you know the poop bag so he he knocked
on the door on the in the Ring app uh
she talked to him on the Ring app
you know a jacket and beanie on but
still you can recognize it
looks cold out there yeah hello
look um it should be dog's just not like
a sloppy [ __ ] outside I was just
wondering if you got some walls I don't
want to leave it outside slap his [ __ ]
outside
you're sure it's just I feel it I feel
terrible you know what I mean
you know what I mean
uh thank you very much once again I'm
sorry about that I hate doing stuff like
that that's why I knocked on go on I'll
see you later
I want a quality guy huh that's such a
cool thing to see oh he's such a good
dude you didn't come with us doing the
Food Drug we did with him and saying no
I wanted to but I didn't know he's such
a good guy yeah such a good person
do you like Jim case
you didn't you you're the one that met
him Hallmark yeah then uh
and park like the next week
oh yeah
oh that's cool yeah he's a good dude
quite just a good that goes a long way
when they they recognize you you know
I'm saying like the celebrity recognizes
like it dude you know the guy who hosts
the he's the main voice on Fox NFL the
black dude the big black guy
forget his name he does not forget a
name
when I worked at Fox I'm out of Psalm
twice dude would never finish Brown
uh no
Kurt Menifee doesn't curse has some
god-given Talent where he does not
forget a name
just remembers everybody's name because
that brenjob like full name what's up
Denver Colorado whoa
it's insane this dude he's such a nice
guy does not for you to name knew
everybody man
yeah I heard uh Tom Cruise is like that
I'm the opposite of that
dude I think all of us remember I know I
never forget a face your name and I feel
bad too but it's my girl's friends
I've known for nine years couldn't tell
you their name
yeah it's tough man and you meet way
more people than we do so I can't
imagine but I always run her face like
can we do meet and greets yeah like
we're in Houston I've been there a while
I'm like oh we've met before last time I
was here like holy [ __ ] I'm like I never
forget a face won't remember your name
ever but I won't forget a face well
that's good then
uh all right so this is
we heard the news at a year prashka he
can't fight for the title all right
sorry to defend his title against Glover
because the shoulder now here's the
thing here's what's alarming and Dana
says when the worst shoulder yeah she's
ever seen
when they didn't just postpone it you
know and make the other fight the main
event when they do an intern Bell and he
has to vape when he has to vacate the
belt that means it's a terrible injury
not good dude not good at all such a
shame yeah
uh but since he had her vacated belt
um a few things happened so first of all
now Margaret met Uncle EV he's going to
be fighting Jan blockovich for that I'm
so curious what this does the
pay-per-view numbers
it's not as exciting it can't be good
it's a great fight but magumat is a
Savage you know Glover turned out in the
fight yeah so that's the other part of
the story was like I'm good I'm good he
says too much of a difference
he needs time to train oh you're talking
about a complete
difference yeah different Global that
shows the veteran in Clover yeah I'm not
I'm no fool exactly the public clearance
laying somebody on uh Monument to get
the job done he's currently at minus 240
betting favorite
that's pretty big especially for I mean
this is a previous champion who defended
his belt I think he told him like mad is
a
problem but again I'm curious what it's
going to do for the for the
pay-per-views you know it doesn't seem
like a huge fight I mean just yeah
now uh Patty's the comet event and
that's Patty's toughest test too this is
a great card it's a great card you know
it's a great gun
but it does 200 000 pay reviews
um
maybe 150
but the the buys didn't come off Patty
if you look at the names I mean the the
general fan knows Robbie Lawler
Till's comeback but you have you have
Patty and you have till so you got a
heavy English fan out there but their
pay-per-views don't count towards ours
right they haven't they gotta free or
something yeah a different thing out
there
uh Jan margument it's a great fight
Patty Jared Gordon great fight Robbie
Lawler pontoonibio fantastic Darren till
duplicates fantastic fight Bryce
Mitchell it's a pro that's a great fight
rosenstruke and uh docus
shabazzian
yeah this really is a good card yeah
oh that's the card we're doing a [ __ ]
thing for huh I hope so
yeah we are dude don't hope December 10.
yeah plan to work perfect don't help I
said I hope so yeah don't hope Daddy
it's happening
all right uh here are some doubt
announcements this one's not official
but Ali Abdel Aziz says that Henry
suhuto versus algeman Sterling is done
because it's done deal for 2023 not an
exact month but it doesn't really work
like that and all these listen if you
want a manager he's a great manager
because he'll put pressure on the UFC
who do stuff like this and he's also the
most famous manager so when he tweets
them out people listen right because
so he builds it up
listen we just had Al Jermaine on food
truck and he was like I need time off
man I'm not I'm not fighting here soon
anytime soon he's like and also I want
to fight sugar next that's the fight
sugar wants next too I don't see the UFC
bending over backwards where Henry Sue
to get in there and Dethrone Al Jermaine
Sterling anytime soon
Al Jermaine and uh sugar is the fight
that's the fight for a variety of
reasons
and then have Henry so who don't fight
the champ
he's been gone long enough to work and
wait a little bit more yeah it's not
like you know if he's out a little long
it's all good
and I I think Henry Sue would be the
favorite in both those matchups I don't
see you'll see because again
how long Henry Sue we can stick around
he's just gonna come in Dethrone
algermane and then what
and then take out sugar and then dip out
and then sugar and aljo fight for the
belt and then it was just like well
those are not really the best we have
you know it's very short-sighted so who
would I be a favorite over both those
gentlemen sudas
top five to ever do it
I'm not yeah two division Weight
Champion Olympic gold medalist nuts
credentials are insane
one of the smartest fighters ever do it
beat Mighty Mouse some think pound for
pound best of all time I mean
it'd be a bad idea to let him get his
hands on either those gentlemen you know
yeah and as a coach he's freaking
amazing too with zangly and for and for
Al Jermaine I you know he's the Champ
for a reason you know he's like no no
I'm fighting Sugarman
he goes I need time off that'd be more
of a fun matchup I think too sugar it's
sell more paper bees yeah
uh another one Jamal Hill oh [ __ ] your
boy versus Anthony Smith March 11. it's
a great fight
great fight Dane big fight for Jamal
Hill yeah and for Anthony Smith
coming soon on future
that'd be great he's making a lot of
headlines full Redemption Gilbert Burns
Neil magni that's a fun one yep
in Rio de Janeiro that's where Gilbert
wanted to fight in Brazil somebody's got
that bag in a fight pier in Brazil I
love Hamza so much dude calling out but
yeah and then yeah dude he's he's insane
yeah UFC's like Jesus Christ for child
dude I know
and this is a cool fight too oh and Drew
Dober and Bobby green great fight it's a
lot of food truck alumni fight I know it
is this 2023 but it just means the end
of uh 2022. so it's at UFC was it 22 as
well that's uh December or when is that
fight then did December keep going down
I just had it December 17th
yeah okay oh that's on the Sean
Strickland Canon air card okay but that
is the end of this year so yeah yeah
this also pretty crazy Nikita Karloff
versus Ryan span Ryan span who just
knocked out Dominic Reyes yeah yeah
they're headlining it's a good fight for
25th headlining five rounds
and this is a real quick one Macy Barber
and Andrea Lee
the only reason Andrew Lee always Pops
in my head is because of her Nazi ex
husband or whatever oh that's right
whatever happened that guy I don't know
dude he was on the run for a while but I
think they got him on the Run storm in
the capital probably
interesting yeah Macy Barber who's a
Colorado girl I love Macy Barber we
gotta get on food truck we were we had a
plan too and then some someone someone
else got booked but we're working on it
alrighty
this I thought was really interesting
because so I guess after Michael's fight
with Oliveira he got ranked number two
in pound for pound of all time right or
you know right now and however Amanda
said he needs to do more he goes yeah
that's just too high of a ranking for
now like it was all based off of one
fight with Oliveira
yeah I'm with I'll be honest but this
same Javier toast he's the best
lightweight ever no he said ever yeah
before even being a world champion so
like you know this is just
look you know this just as much as I do
is I went to number two pound per pound
in the UFC in just one fight I know he's
good I believe he's number one I do
believe that but to give him numbers two
spot pounds around just one fight I know
my heart with time would be number one
simply as that he's gonna be number one
the game this just because one fight no
I don't like that it's done too quickly
also Javier you gotta realize who makes
the pound for pound list and you have
the number one Fighter versus the number
two pound for pound fighter coming up in
February you have Islam versus
volkanovsky so it's for the number one
spot that's how they're gonna sell the
thing it's marketing because pound for
pound really doesn't matter does it yeah
it's all Up For Debate yeah that's what
they're doing so you can Mark as number
one verse number two not only is the
light uh lightweight title on the line
the and the guy coming up with 45 on the
line pound for pounds on the line
somebody's o has got to go
that makes sense because Mike Jeff is
already lost but you know what I'm
saying
all right give me one more chance we've
been doing a seven hour show I know so
this is the one I wanted to say because
Mark put this on our group chat so Paula
Costa his story about Israel Israel
adesanya stylebender which I thought was
freaking awesome but let me see if this
loads and now it's Paulo Casa for sure
find out Whitaker in February I remember
he's waiting for some dispute with his
contract I know for mostly he's not
finalized but UFC's I guess it is
a really nice guy I remember we're doing
a meet and greet uh signing he said
meeting great signing uh autographs and
taking pictures before UFC 253 and Abu
Dhabi just before we finish and go out
the baby started crying the queue that
means the line free Americans I'll sign
your clock this and gently asked the
mother if he could help her with the
prom he gently grabbed the baby sat down
his seat uh with the baby the baby I
know he's he pulled up his shirt and
breastfed the baby there and then true
hero if that didn't speak to someone's
personality then I don't know what well
so just trolling but it's just done so
well yeah especially for Paul Acosta I
didn't know he was this funny dude he's
funny yeah he's funny
kicking a guy when he's done I know that
sucks but it's just you know no it's
just a super obvious joke so it's not
too crazy
um
no no I'll save it for later
see
is that it brother that is it hold on so
we have I mean if you want to talk about
the fights again but it's up to you uh
the whole card's fired the the I broke
down the Wonder Boy and Kevin Holland
fight I'm taking Kevin Holland I think
he's done in five rounds I'm taking
black belt and crazy over a veteran uh
you know Father Time Wonder Boy Thompson
uh Brian barbarino Rafael dosanchos
Brian barbarino is gonna make that a
complete War he's been on this
just Rampage beating Legends I think uh
dos Santos could be next on that list uh
our boy tied to evaso there should be
somewhere in here it's something I think
the boys have been using it you've tied
to avasa fighting Eric Anders Kyle dukak
is a great fight Nico price AKA Andrew
Schultz Angel Hill Emily ducoli clay
Guida Scott holtzman's a fun one Michael
Johnson uh Darren Elkins Tracy Cortez
that's Brian Ortega's girl it's a great
Fight Night Finale Fight Night
um I'll take I'll take Tai to avasa I'll
take uh Kyle du Cox Dukakis and I'll
take uh by Arena and Kevin Holland
so you have that going on Saturday night
and then like I told you guys the best
fight of the weekend
um if you're not familiar with the boys
over at one Championship you need to get
familiar the most talented fighter this
weekend is fighting
DeRidder we call him RDR in one
championship this dude is the light
heavyweight champion the middleweight
champion he's undefeated going against
the undefeated interim heavyweight
champion of the world the Russian and
Malik Malkin it is going down all right
on Saturday I'm always confused by the
times there because it's in uh Singapore
it's going down on Amazon one
Championship on Prime video five check
out the most talented dude I think in
one Championship again the middleweight
champion the light heavyweight champion
he want to draw against [ __ ] uh uh
gal Val and straight up Jiu Jitsu he was
a 80cc uh gold medalist he is a complete
Savage it's RDR it's Ritter D Ritter the
Dutch Knight himself is going against a
non-defeated heavyweight Russian Savage
and Malkin that all goes down on One
Prime video it's one Championship baby
it's the last one of the Year tune in
and hope you enjoyed the show I will be
off uh to Providence Rhode Island this
Thursday Friday Saturday Providence
Rhode Island at the comedy connection
it's the last tour date in 2022. come
get you some for the oh he thick tour
and then don't forget next Friday 5 p.m
Pacific it's rough and rowdy bar stool
is jumping on board the thick boy train
it will be live on thick boy YouTube
December 9th 8 P.M Eastern 5 p.m Pacific
all right you can watch the boys Theo
Von Uncle Joey Coco Diaz Rampage Jackson
myself it's rough and rowdy19 it's going
down Barstool Sports rough and rowdy
thick boy 5 p.m Pacific thick boy
YouTube make sure you tune into that and
we have a companion the next Saturday as
well alright kids hope you enjoyed it
hope you had a great Thanksgiving
hopefully you're rested let's get back
to work love you guys stay thick I'm out
[Applause]
for three
two Division World Champion anybody in
the world I'm finished I'll strangle
anybody on the planet that man is a
beast he is awesome
Holland is here if you give this man
your neck it will put you to sleep
hockey Brash confident to the point of
arrogance but you know what he has
backed it up bring your durita still
undefeated get this
with birth of a legend
you pick the place but keep that belt
shining because I'm coming for it
[Music]
oh my word bring your Dorita does what
many thoughts impossible
now he wants to take onwar's light
heavyweight well tied up what they said
could not be done
[Music]
you want to do a big Champions I beat
every four thank you
champ for a reason I dominate people and
I finish them it's just another day in
the office I need to show the world I'm
the best that's what I'm here for him
if you're into thick boys
like subscribe comment
and God bless America well that's not my
big one just kidding